now for this next task what we'd like
you to do is actually hook up mouse move
and key down to proper listener events
so that we can receive and then respond
to those two actions appropriately now
remember the proper syntax to add an
event listener is as such make sure you
utilize this while filling out your code
now for mouse move the event object
itself will contain two properties that
you'll need to use the client x and
client white values represent the
position of the mouse on the canvas
itself not on the web page so make sure
you take that into account the on key
down event instead of containing a
client x and client y contains a key id
property